- Yeah, the other burger just looks more.
(burps)
- Sorry.
- Put together.
- (laughing) Sorry.
- Veggie burgers, veggie
burgers, (cheering)
- Feast mode hunger squad,
we're going to be traveling
all over Los Angeles today.
- And our mission today is to find
the best veggie burger in L.A.
- We're going to play
Veggie Burger Telephone.
- And what happens is
we go to one restaurant,
we try the veggie burger.
- And then ask them where they would go
if they weren't eating
their own veggie burger.
- And then we're going to keep going on,
and on and on until we find...
- The best one in L.A.
- For me, as a vegetarian,
it's pretty hard to find
a good veggie burger.
- I don't think I've ever
actually eaten a veggie burger,
so this will be interesting.
I'm a big meat fan.
I don't care what's in a burger,
as long as it tastes
good I'm down for that.
- I need a few more spots
to eat veggie burgers at
because most of the ladies
in Los Angeles are vegan,
as we all know.
- I am a vegetarian, I am a vegetarian.
- We are on our way right
now to Cafe Gratitude.
We gotta make up a rubric here.
What makes a good veggie burger?
- Oh, okay first it's not too mushy.
It's not real meat, it
can't be mushy, firmness.
Flavor, obviously.
Presentation.
- I'm always worried
with the veggie burger
that I'm not going have a full meal.
- Let's do it, let's do it.
Oh, God I'm so hungry and
I'm stuck, oh sweet Jesus.
So, this is our first
stop for veggie burgers.
Tell us about Cafe Gratitude.
- We're all all-organic,
all-vegan establishment.
We are just kind of a casual,
fun place where you can
bring anyone from your
dog to your grandma.
You're going to be
having the I Am Magical,
which is our double
cheeseburger with our black bean
and mushroom and all sorts
of spices in the patties.
- Will it make me full?
- Oh, it will definitely make you full.
I like to refer to it
as the Boyfriend Burger.
- [Colin] First off, this
burger looks pretty neat.
- Patties are maybe a
quarter of an inch thick.
I'm gonna give it a four on presentation.
- [Colin] You know, there's
always room for growth.
- [Mallory] I like the texture a lot.
- Tastes like a salad.
- Mine is falling apart.
- Steven's eating like a child.
- This is not firm.
- Firmness is a three for me.
- The flavors are good, though.
- A whole sprig of rosemary
in there, it's good.
- Flavor, I'll give it a four.
- Bonus, this would fill me up.
- Uh, I don't know.
- How much do you eat?
I would give it a four.
- One thing I do know
about this sandwich is
it is nutritious AF.
- [Steven] Look at Colin trying to fit in
with the kids, these days.
- I think we are eternally
grateful to Cafe Gratitude.
But it is time to move on.
- If you weren't going to
eat a veggie burger here,
where would you go next?
- My go-to is probably
Sun Cafe in Studio City.
- It's my turn to drive,
and I'm going to take us to the Valley.
- [Colin] Jordan's from Boston.
I know how people from Boston drive.
- I'm a perfect driver.
- Vegetarians on average
fart like 10 times more
than meat eaters.
- [Jordan] Beans, beans,
are good for your heart,
the more you eat, the more you fart.
- [Steven] Hey, don't run over that girl.
- [Jordan] Steven.
I will (bleep) kill you.
So, Cafe Gratitude sent us here
to try your veggie burgers.
But first you want to
just tell us a little bit
about the restaurant?
- We make all our own cheese from scratch
out of seeds and nuts so
everything's super fresh.
We have our traditional one
which is our raw burger.
Then we also have a new
one that we just introduced
which is a marinated tempeh burger.
- I've never had tempeh,
so I don't know what I'm about to eat.
- I freaking love tempeh.
- Cheers, we're going,
we're going, we're going.
- [Jordan] That's interesting.
- Smooth consistency, nice and firm.
Whatever it is, this is a soy product
and it's a delicious one.
- Are you a tempeh fan?
- I don't know.
- It's like a pretty good burger,
but it feels more like a sandwich.
All right, let's move onto the raw,
which I'm super stoked about.
- [Jordan] That's really good.
- What's this creamy sauce on the bottom?
- It's got kind of a meaty flavor to it,
which is interesting.
- [Mallory] Did you bring your own napkin?
- [Jordan] You know they gave you napkins.
- I did.
(laughter)
- It is firm.
- Yeah.
- Firmess, five.
Fullness, five.
Presentation, five.
Flavor, five.
- You're too generous, you're like Oprah.
I would say it's a 4.5.
Whoa, actually no, now on
second thought it's a five.
It definitely holds together.
- Yeah, it moves like a burger.
- There's a lot of
flavors to work through,
but like all really great flavors.
- Overall, I would bring a date here.
Not this one, but a date.
- I'm legit so full right now.
Like, I don't know how I'm
going to do another restaurant.
- If you weren't going to
eat a veggie burger here,
where would you go to eat a veggie burger?
- I've heard some good
things about Beachwood Cafe.
- It's gonna be hard to top this place.
- Seriously.
- But it's time to go to Beachwood.
(Colin yawning)
- Ah, dag it.
- [Steven] Honestly, I don't
know what this place can do
that could be better than Sun Cafe.
- This spot is definitely
like classic veggie diner.
- What we're gonna do is we want to order
veggie burgers for us.
You guys have them here?
- Yes, we make our own
veggie burgers here.
(laughter)
- [Steven] This is what I expect
a veggie burger to look like.
- It smells really good.
- [Colin] I would say it's like
very classic American fare.
- [Mallory] This is the only
burger that was open face.
- But open face is better.
- Yeah, presentation.
- You can wait for it to be
fresh until you actually eat it.
- [Mallory] I'm going to
go four on presentation.
Do we want to spread the avocado, maybe?
- Where's the brown rice?
Oh, it's in the patty.
- [Mallory] It's in the
patty, all right here we go.
- Hm, good patty.
- It's um, chewy.
- It's like a three.
- I like 2.5.
This is not as firm as I
would have wanted it to be.
- This will fill me up,
this is a full meal.
- I'm gonna say five on
fullness because it's just like
a patty and rice.
- I like the flavor, it gives
you like a home feeling,
like a warm feeling.
- It's like the inside of
a Chipotle burrito bowl.
- It didn't blow my mind.
- I'm going three on flavor.
- I've got a food baby AF.
- (bleep) finish it.
- My favorite burger was
the raw burger at Sun Cafe.
- We ate a lot of good burgers,
but that one was off the charts good.
- I'm glad that we found
places where I can go
and also bring a vegetarian.
- After today, I think I'm less
skeptical of veggie burgers.
- I think I've added a
few more pretty choice
date spots to my repetoire.
- For sure.
- Feast mode fam, whoo.
- They're going to have
good poops tonight.
We're all going to have
it really easy peasy.
The fiber just like makes it
just go (vocal sound effects).
- [Jordan] If we all ate a
lot of fiber we'd have easy.
- Do you squash (bleep)?